vamos a empezar tomando ave digamos que
sea un sub espacio sub espacio de rn es
decir de nuestro espacio de n
dimensiones y vamos a considerar ahora
vamos a realmente definir algo que vamos
a llamar el complemento ortogonal el
complemento ortogonal de nuestro espacio
be ok el complemento ortogonal del
espacio be ok y vamos a definirlo de la
siguiente forma vamos primero a decir
como se escribe vamos a denotar lo como
be y con este simbolito pequeño de que
es perpendicular o que es ortogonal y
que de hecho vamos a decir b
perpendicular o be ortogonal y esto va a
ser el conjunto de todos los vectores en
en rn ok todos los vectores en rn tales
que al hacer el producto punto de x con
b va a ser igual a 0 pero para todos ve
en nuestro espacio en nuestro sub
espacio de mayúsculas es decir esto va a
ocurrir para todo
para todo sector en nuestro sub espacio
ve y lo importante es que es para todos
ok entonces éste sube espacio lo que me
está habido oeste este conjunto lo que
me está diciendo es que si yo tengo un
sub espacio ve que tiene a lo mejor
muchísimos vectores estamos encontrando
un conjunto donde todos los vectores que
se encuentren en este conjunto be
ortogonal o el complemento ortogonal de
b sea todos los lectores sean
ortogonales a todos los de nuestro sub
espacio de mayúscula ok entonces una vez
que ya hemos definido este conjunto pues
la primera pregunta y que es muy
inmediata es bueno será be be ortogonal
o el complemento ortogonal debe un sub
espacio es decir el complemento
ortogonal de be es su espacio
y es una pregunta que siempre que
definamos algunos conjuntos de este
estilo pues vale la pena preguntarnos
por qué de esta forma vamos a poder
aplicar todo lo que ya sabemos de sus
espacios a estos en particular ok y
recordemos que significa que algo sea un
sub espacio es decir si nos tomamos dos
vectores cualesquiera digamos ahí ve en
nuestro de ortogonal que es lo que
tenemos que preguntarnos bueno primero
será cierto que la suma de a más b se
encuentre en be ortogonal y esto nos
estaría diciendo que se ha cerrado bajo
su más verdad será cierto esto esto es
lo que nos estamos preguntando otra
pregunta será cierto que la
multiplicación de s de cualquier escalar
de cualquier número real por nuestro
vector a se encuentra también en en el
complemento ortogonal
esa es otra pregunta y bueno hay gente
que dice bueno será cierto que el 0 está
en el complemento ortogonal pero ese es
redundante porque si tenemos que esto es
válido para cualquier se constante pues
en particular si multiplicamos por la
constante 0 ok entonces vamos a vamos a
considerar esto de aquí estamos tomando
los dos vectores en el complemento
ortogonal que significa esto esto
significa que a punto b a punto b es
igual a 0 para cualquier o para todo
para todo b que se encuentre en nuestro
psuv espacio b mayúscula ahora también
como b b de esta vez este vector b que
se encuentra en el complemento ortogonal
quiere decir que si hacemos el producto
interior o el producto punto con este v
nos va a dar 0 para todo también para
todo v en nuestro espacio en nuestro
psuv espacio original ok entonces
la pregunta que queremos responder es si
la suma si la suma se encuentra en el
sub espacio entonces más perdón en el
complemento ortogonal entonces tenemos
que tomar además de hacer el producto en
punto con cualquier vector cualquiera
que se encuentre en nuestro espacio v y
esto como es distributivo tenemos que va
a ser a punto b a punto de más de punto
v y como ambos eran estos dos productos
punto son 0 por esta propiedad que
tenemos aquí esto pues simplemente va a
ser 0 +0 que finalmente es 0 entonces
nuestra primera pregunta es cierta esto
fue válido sí es cierto que la suma se
encuentra en el complemento ortogonal
ahora la siguiente pregunta es si
multiplicamos un vector por una
constante c y luego lo multiplicamos por
el vector v eso será cero y la respuesta
vamos a ver por qué podemos sacar la
costa
que multiplique al producto a este
producto punto y otra vez como a se
encontraba en el complemento ortogonal
esto vale 0 es decir esto es ce por 0
que es igual a 0 entonces nuestra
segunda pregunta también es cierta
también es cierto que al multiplicar por
una constante se queda dentro de este
complemento ortogonal y y queda claro
que el 0 el vector 0 es parte de este
espacio de este de este conjunto
complemento ortogonal porque 0 por
cualquier cosa por cualquier otro vector
sigue siendo ser y de hecho eso nos está
diciendo que cualquier sube espacio
cualquier complemento ortogonal de
cualquier sub espacio siempre tiene al
menos un elemento y que es al cero muy
bien entonces lo que acabamos de
concluir aquí es que el espacio del
complemento ortogonal desde el sub
espacio v es un sub espacio
un sub espacio y ya podemos utilizar
todos los resultados que tenemos de sub
espacios para en particular a los
complementos ortogonales muy bien
entonces vamos a platicar un poco de lo
que teníamos en otros vídeos vamos a
considerar a una matriz de m por n muy
bien y recordemos que habíamos afirmado
en alguno de los vídeos que el espacio
nulo el espacio nulo de nuestra matriz a
que es el complemento ortogonal es el
complemento
el complemento ortogonal ya habíamos
dicho que era el complemento ortogonal
del espacio fila del espacio fila oa
veces se le dice espacio renglón depende
del gusto quizás yo usé ambos de repente
todo va a ser el complemento ortogonal
del espacio fila de nuestra matriz a ok
entonces el espacio fila no es otra cosa
más que el espacio columna el espacio
columna de nuestra matriz a pero
transpuesta porque es decir
intercambiando renglones por columnas en
otra en otra forma de escribirlo podemos
decir que el no en el núcleo o el vuelo
o el espacio nulo de nuestra matriz a
son también dos formas de llamarlo es
tomar el complemento ortogonal del
espacio fila o el espacio columna de la
matriz transpuesta
este es el complemento ortogonal y
déjenme remarcar aquí esto vamos a
ponerlo re marcado con rojo para que
quede mucho más claro ok entonces el
espacio nulo es el complemento ortogonal
del espacio fila que el espacio fila es
el espacio columna de nuestra matriz
transpuesta ok entonces esto es una esta
es una proposición y falta realmente
demostrar esto entonces vamos a vamos a
intentar hacerlo vamos a considerar
vamos a considerar una matriz
déjenme hacerlo con otro color vamos a
considerar nuestra matriz
como vamos a escribirlo de esta forma
vamos a escribir quienes son sus
renglones déjenme hacerlo con verde para
que quede más colorido el asunto y
entonces aquí vamos a tener como primer
renglón a un vector r 1 transpuesto y le
pongo transpuesto porque siempre hemos
estado trabajando con vectores columna
principalmente ok aquí vamos a tener
otro vector r 2 transpuesto ok y vamos a
ir así hasta nuestra m nuestra nuestro
renglón m si quizás te puede estar
confundiendo esto de que sea un vector
transpuesto en realidad no te fijes
mucho en eso solo considera que aquí
estamos pensando que r 1 es el vector
que forma esta fila r 2 es el vector que
forma esta otra fila y así sucesivamente
hasta el vector r m ok entonces esta es
nuestra matriz a y vamos a multiplicarlo
por un vector x
y vamos a multiplicar esto por un vector
x que digamos que va a ser igual a el
vector
es decir el vector que tiene cero en
todas las entradas
que estamos diciendo estamos suponiendo
aquí si tomamos un vector x tal que al
multiplicarlo por la matriz a nos da el
vector 0 estamos pensando que este x
está en el núcleo o en o en el espacio
nulo de nuestra matriz y esa es la
definición del espacio nulo ok entonces
solo hay que recordar que es lo que
ocurre cuando consideramos este este
producto de una matriz por un vector por
qué porque si nosotros consideramos esto
en realidad estamos pensando que esta
primera entrada el resultado del
producto punto de este renglón con este
vector x es decir que esto esté 0 va a
ser igual a r 1 punto nuestro vector x y
es y eso ocurre para cada uno de los de
las entradas de este vector es decir
para este segundo nos tomaremos a este
vector r 2 ok vamos a tomarnos ere 2 r2
vamos a hacer el producto punto con el
vector x y nos debe dar 0 y eso debe
ocurrir de forma análoga con todas las
entradas de este vector nulo aunque yo
otra forma de escribirlo sería de la
siguiente forma que r 1 r 1 punto x debe
ser igual a 0 es otra forma de
reescribir este esta ecuación que
también r 2 punto x nos debe dar 0 y así
sucesivamente esto debe pasar con todos
los vectores r hasta el rm que hacemos
el producto punto con x y nos debe dar
también
muy bien entonces fijémonos muy bien qué
es lo que hemos estado escribiendo
porque esencialmente podemos decir que
nos tomamos un vector digamos de uno en
el en el espacio nulo de nuestra matriz
a ok nos tomamos este b1 que informa
sería digamos el papel que juega en esta
ecuación la equis y como nos lo tomamos
en el espacio nulo al multiplicarlo por
la matriz a nos debe dar el vector 0 esa
es la definición del espacio nulo verdad
es decir el espacio nulo de una matriz
el espacio nulo de esta matriz es el
conjunto de vectores x en este caso r n
tal que al multiplicar la matriz por el
vector nos debe dar el vector 0 es la
definición del espacio nulo entonces sí
ya nos hemos tomado un vector en el
espacio nulo
quiere decir que al multiplicarlo por la
matriz nos da 0 pero esta multiplicación
de la matriz de la matriz por el vector
no es otra cosa más que el vector que
tiene por entradas
los productos punto d el renglón con el
vector por ejemplo éste es r 1 punto x
el segundo es r 2 punto equis y así
sucesivamente pero si eso nos da 0
quiere decir que de 1
satisface estas ecuaciones y eso quiere
decir que es ortogonal es ortogonal a
todos los raíz es decir es ortogonal a
r1 y r2 y así sucesivamente a todos
hasta ere m ahora bien esto que nos está
diciendo si es ortogonal a todos ellos
lo que yo afirmo es que también va a ser
ortogonal a cualquier combinación lineal
de ellos es decir que de uno es
ortogonal ortogonal
toda combinación lineal
la combinación
combinación vamos a escribirlo completo
lineal
de estos ere is ok y de hecho es muy
sencillo observar esto por ejemplo
consideremos no sé un vector wv vamos a
decir que w sea una combinación de estos
ere y digamos que sea
c 1 x r 1 más de 2 x r 2 más
etcétera todos estos suman 2 hasta c m
por r
m ok este va a ser nuestro vector w
ahora vamos a ver quién sería entonces
déjenme dejarlo con morado quién sería
entonces b punto w porque si hacemos el
producto interior sabemos que esto
distribuye la suma entonces si hacemos b
punto w
sacamos digamos todas las constantes y
hacemos de punto cada uno de estos
vectores y sumamos en pocas palabras
estoy escribiendo c 1 por b punto r 1
todos estos sumandos hasta c m por b
punto r m ok pero pero dijimos que era
ortogonal a cada uno de ellos verdad
esto quiere decir que estos términos se
cancelan valen 0 y entonces este
producto interior al final valió
simplemente 0 por lo tanto b es
ortogonal a cualquier combinación lineal
de estos vectores muy bien eso quiere
decir que doble que perdón que ve es
ortogonal a cualquier elemento verdad a
cualquier elemento del espacio fila de a
el recordemos que el espacio fila de a
es el espacio generado por estos
renglones pero si esos el espacio
generado por los renglones es el espacio
de todas las combinaciones lineales de
esos vectores por lo tanto si fue
ortogonal a todos ellos será ortogonal a
cualquier combinación lineal y por lo
tanto vamos a escribirlo formalmente
y vamos a tener que si tenemos un w si
nos tomamos un w
en el espacio fila de nuestra matriz a o
lo que es lo mismo el espacio columna de
la matriz transpuesta y nos tomamos un b
un vector b en el espacio nulo de
nuestra matriz entonces ocurre que de
punto w es igual a 0 es decir son
ortogonales esto lo que nos está
diciendo es que todo elemento todo
elemento que se encuentre en el espacio
nulo de a ok es ortogonal es ortogonal
es ortogonal a cada elemento como aquí
estamos viendo a cada elemento del
espacio fila del espacio fila
el espacio fila o el espacio renglón de
nuestra matriz a muy bien ok entonces
qué es lo que estamos diciendo aquí si
nos tomamos cualquier elemento del
espacio nulo de a va a estar también en
el complemento ortogonal del espacio
fila de a eso nos está diciendo
inmediatamente que nuestro espacio nulo
nuestro espacio nulo de la matriz está
completamente contenido en él
en el complemento ortogonal de nuestro
espacio fila
ok eso nos está diciendo que todo este
conjunto está metido en este otro ahora
la afirmación que nosotros teníamos acá
arriba es que eran iguales así que lo
único que nos falta ver es que este otro
conjunto está contenido en el espacio
nulo de nuestra matriz ok entonces nos
falta demostrar que el espacio el
complemento ortogonal del espacio fila
de la matriz está también contenido en
el espacio nulo de a como vamos a
demostrar eso bueno tomémonos un
elemento en este conjunto cualquiera
arbitrario y veamos que también está en
el espacio nulo entonces tomemos digamos
un o un vector y que se encuentre en el
complemento ortogonal de el espacio fila
ok nos tomamos este elemento y entonces
esto lo que nos está diciendo es que 1.2
w es igual a 0 verdad esto es lo que nos
está diciendo donde www se encuentra
pues en el espacio en el espacio columna
de la matriz transpuesta que es lo mismo
que el espacio fila de a muy bien
entonces si esto es cierto para
cualquier w que se encuentra aquí en
particular podemos considerar los
renglones de nuestra matriz es decir que
un punto
rj es igual a cero siempre que donde
jota es igual a 12 etcétera todos hasta
m verdad entonces esto nos está diciendo
que un punto r uno es cero
que un punto r 2
déjenme poner bien las flechitas también
es 0 todos van a ser 0 hasta un punto r
m todos estos son 0 y si todos esos son
0 inmediatamente me está diciendo que si
yo hiciera la multiplicación de la
matriz
con un a
y esto me va a dar 0 verdad justamente
por lo que habíamos dicho arriba
justamente por lo que habíamos dicho
arriba esto esta ecuación se cumple
entonces vamos a dejarlo así y esto
implicaría que uno se encuentra en el en
el espacio nulo de nuestra matriz a muy
bien entonces ya hemos demostrado
también con esto que el complemento
vamos a escribirlo así que el
complemento ortogonal de nuestro
verde bueno si es verde pero uno muy
malo entonces tenemos que el complemento
ortogonal del espacio fila
está también contenido en el núcleo de
nuestra matriz correcto ok en el núcleo
o en el espacio nulo es lo mismo pero si
tenemos que el espacio nulo está
contenido en el complemento ortogonal
del espacio fila y tenemos la otra
contención no le queda otra cosa más que
sean iguales verdad entonces podemos
concluir ya con todo que el espacio nulo
de la matriz es igual al complemento
ortogonal del espacio fila del de la
matriz ok complemento ortogonal ahora
bien vamos a hacer una pequeña
observación y déjenme hacerlo acá arriba
con otro color
qué pasaría si por ejemplo
fuera una matriz transpuesta siempre
puede ser la transporta de otra matriz
verdad de hecho de aes la transpuesta
sea transpuesta entonces quien sería el
núcleo en el núcleo o el espacio nulo
debe transpuesta pues esto según esta
igualdad sería el complemento ortogonal
de el espacio columna de la trans puesta
desde transpuesta verdad
y creo que ya me estoy saliendo un poco
déjenme escribirlo bien déjenme moverme
un poquito más a la izquierda
por acá entonces estamos diciendo que si
ya es una matriz transpuesta entonces lo
que vamos a tener es que el espacio nulo
desde transpuesta va a ser el
complemento ortogonal de él transpuesto
de ésta de transpuesta verdad
complemento ortogonal pero quienes la
transpuesta de b transpuesta pues esto
simplemente es b quiere decir que el
espacio nulo debe transpuesta va a ser
igual al complemento ortogonal de b muy
bien esto nos está diciendo que el
espacio nulo el espacio nulo izquierdo
es el complemento ortogonal del espacio
columna de hecho bueno ya habíamos hecho
un ejemplo particular hace algunos
vídeos pero ahora hemos visto que todas
estas afirmaciones son ciertas para
cualquier matriz